am ende müsse hier bewerten welche die
schönste kopfbedeckung von jakob war
doch keine gehabt nur vage oder die
mutter ein bisschen lauter ich habe das
gefühl man gehört ist mit stephen henley
es braucht keine mutter also mein vater
ist anscheinend auch im stream hören sie
mir als mich in den letzten tagen nicht
gemeldet habe aber wenigstens bekommst
du so eben was tun wir mit wir packen
jetzt kekse das wird also nicht das
allerbeste sonst lass ich es auch nicht
ich weiß nicht ganz schaffen
er kommt erst mal mit ist oder weil hier
die einen denken an diesen weg so weiter
so kambodscha milliarde eier und müssen
wir sogar darauf verzichten weil sonntag
gestern natürlich ist das eine wg oder
mutter alleine durch moment ja kommt
zusammen wie gesagt in der aachener
straße 52 kommt alle vorbei 50674 köln
möglichst in allen und tom ist nicht so
richtig wäre das ist aber die lena
kommen weiß nicht wer es mag sein dass
du irgendwas zum platzen dekorieren da
so sträußchen oder so sagt dass er
zumindest wasserstoffperoxid was kommt
jetzt
hallo mein guter helfer gegen
ebenso bremer hammer geil
die erste station war ich küsse dich
[Musik]
sagt max heimerl schon von der rtr ist
die bunker eigentlich noch an ganz 250
gramm mehl und glaube ich 125 gramm
zucker das ist nun richtig erwartet
werden sonst am wichtigsten
[Musik]
italien weiterhin schon fertig so viele
leute
weitere potter nicht plötzlich nehmen
soll
egal was kommt haben wir das eigentlich
schon ganz oben kein verlag haben du
hast gesagt wochen backpapier gegenüber
neuen rabatt auf die norm stellt jetzt
von der nein diesen trichter die eure
mir nicht ein gute gute 1
aber sonntag 19.30 bisschen kennt die
frage stellt sich jetzt nicht weil
direkt habe ich nicht gelesen einzelnen
chef beim losen auch werbung habt könnt
ihr sie fand von ihr wisst doch gar
nicht was euch erwartet dass wir so
verwirrt was diesen dezember noch
passiert das ja schon nicht selbst
fahrrad oder tatsächlich falsch in köln
meistens mit ähnlich schnell von a nach
b zu kommen sind die hier in münster
trafen jacob reicht nicht sagt wie es
ist vor chelsea 42 20 grundsätzlich
keine vorsätze halt wenig ein
aber ich weiß leider schon was bekommen
einen esstisch papa
es wird wieder du wolltest du übrigens
könnt und stuhl zu einer kommt mit der
nase los da weil es jetzt auch nicht
mehr zu
von bis zu zehn euro oder sowas
kleinster treffen uns einen abend alle
zusammen so feierten am 20 vor oder am
19 mit allen nach weihnachten kommt
relativ schnell schon silvester lief
verbringt ihr euer
das war nicht mal eine frage meine frage
war sondern zwei wagen in einer schleife
die hat mir meine adventskalender fertig
habt ihr natürlich sehr genau war in
einem bahnhof und wollte meinen ersten
advents türchen aufgemacht wie cola co
da kommt meine mutter hat gesagt alles
was doppelt ist dass in dem hellen als
einzige dich dass du heute davon liegt
natürlich sabine empfehlen da wirklich
sehr kritisch fahrräder ja und ja kommen
sie zusammen ein auto an bord safe
harbor worden sagt wie es ist stellte
mich an bord gefahren bin war ich nur
noch mehr aber welche auf korrekt von
köln nach sieben will wenn ich auf
meinen harbort und du schneller sie war
dass er von falschen oder wegschiebt
[Musik]
jegliche kopf wieder frei
doch jakob ist tatsächlich wirklich
[Musik]
natürlich ist max auto gut ist ja auch
der outfit tragen hier den pulli und
personen mit alter werden die jeans und
schuhe an sollte das ist das recht eure
namen lässt sich erkennen dass ihre
texte meinte tricks machen ja klar keine
politik zu machen überlegt werde ob ich
genial wenn wir wasser enthält was wir
machen können doch nicht die 22
nein bitte nicht mag
[Musik]
vielleicht habt ihr das kelly war mail
auf ihrem weißen nach dem schwarzen
körper ich habe einmal ein verweist
dafür bekommen dass sie beim touren
magnesium auf meiner mama und
handabdrücke auf dem rücken von dem
mitschüler aber das ding war der leber
marx ja man will deine geschichte zu
ende
meine geschichte das die leute können
hier die abgehen gut die geschichte trug
sich das paar im sportunterricht und
java jungen mann verdummen mann tötete
und magnesium um den grip an den bahnen
zu verbessern
es waren zu wahren ich habe ja die
magneten die hand gemacht und habe jetzt
immer so ein bisschen bisschen viel
scheiße gebaut in der schule und dann
habe ich mit diesen magnesium hätten
mitschüler wo auch dieses schwarzen
t-shirt auf dem dritten und zwei jahren
sollten wir uns zu der reihe aufstellen
weil er irgendwie sowas sagen wollte
oder so ist also hinter die schüler
gelaufen so dass er vor allem den rücken
sehen konnte und die stadt um gelungen
so sieben plätze weiter von dem typen
solchen kollegen in menschlicher und der
sieht das so dass er mal gestanden und
sagst du direkte der marktpreis einfach
weil er wusste dass ich es gewesen sein
muss die mannschaft und haben noch einen
harten winter in berlin und haben
bereits zur hälfte
also seid jetzt möchte er das erträgt
wie hat der wasser heraus man erst in
pensionen deshalb nicht ihre aufgabe
was wissen wir ja hat zwar keiner
gefragt aber als zeuge nicht erreicht
bekommen habe gepasst und verbreiten
ich glaube sie sich vielfältig wir haben
mitglieder von mir ein verweis bekommen
weil er irgendwie ich mal unterricht
oder scheiße gebaut aber der lehrer war
so ein bisschen verplanten kunstlehrer
und dann hat der kunst wäre dass sie
aufgeschrieben so nahmen klasse dass er
heute sind verwaist erinnerung ist ihr
den abschied dann bin ich aber letztlich
kollegial gefühlt habe bin ich sofort
kurz mit zum lehrer hast du das ja fast
das so auf alibi und habe mein bild aber
auf den zettel gelegt wo er sich die
namen kommen
aufgeschrieben hat dem ausland so dran
geheftet und habe den mitgenommen wenn
man klappern und
schwinden dass du weißt ja gut soll ich
war richtig richtig ehrenmann so habe
für meinen für den geregelt mich dann
mit einem anderen mitschüler gestritten
hatten der das match muss wenn du siehst
das war nicht okay das ist ein schock
wenn du das siehst
[Musik]
wann kommt ein neues dave erklärt
hoffentlich neben diesen schnell zu
langweilig ist das geil aus nichts sagt
[Musik]
bach sind will ich auch gar nichts zu
schaffen
es war sehr schön mit euch das was er
wirklich die besten wein und nicht
direkt auch morgen 16 uhr wir sehen uns